If you’re watching this video on a laptop
in-between watching more cat videos, you may
have noticed the sound of fans whirring away,
trying to keep your slim technological miracle
of form and function cool.
Heat is a natural enemy of electronics, it
can cause computers to slow and crash, and
damage important hardware to boot.
So scientists at Duke University have been
exploring a new technique inspired by insect
wings to keep your CPU as cool as you are.
The concept behind every cooling system ever
is basically the same: take heat from a hot
area, move it to somewhere less hot, repeat
ad infinitum.
The details of how different systems do this
exactly can vary a lot, and they range from
simple to ingenious.
Heat sinks just let the electronics warm a
set of metal fins with a large surface area
while a fan blows cool air over the fins.
The air warms up, absorbing the heat, and
then is blown away.
Only the most powerful pre 90s computers needed
these but now they’re a staple of home computers
and have made higher processing speeds possible.
Heat pipes contain liquid and use heat to
turn it into a vapor, which then travels to
a cooler part of the pipe to condense again.
The liquid then naturally flows back to the
hot areas along grooves on the inside of the
pipe because the liquid is attracted to the
material, a phenomenon called capillary action.
No pumps or gravity are required, so this
is the technique many satellites use to manage
heat in space.
Like a heat pipe, the new system developed
at Duke also uses vaporizing liquid as a means
to carry heat away.
A sponge-like material filled with liquid
rests just under the surface that needs to
be cooled.
The liquid absorbs the heat until it turns
into vapor and leaves the sponge -- taking
the heat with it.
Below the sponge is a cool surface for the
liquid to condense on, but it’s been specially
designed to be superhydrophobic.
I’m not talking regular hydrophobic, like
oil and water.
I mean super-hydrophobic like a cat, it actively
repels it.
It does this by mimicking the microscopic
bumps on the wings of a cicada.
Condensing water droplets sit on these bumps
like a person sits on a bed of nails.
When droplets merge though, they leap into
the air.
This is because when the two droplets come
together, their overall surface area is reduced.
The energy that was once used to keep the
droplets flat on the hydrophobic surface is
suddenly released, popping the drop straight
up.
Cicadas use this phenomenon to keep their
wings clean, while the cooler uses it to return
liquid to the sponge.
There are a few benefits of a cooling system
like this.
It works in any orientation and is independent
of gravity.
It can also passively cool moving hotspots
that naturally occur; If an area of the electronic
device gets hotter than the rest, it’ll
just evaporate more liquid from the sponge.
Other techniques either can’t target hotspots
at all -- making them ill suited to cool large
areas -- or they have to use power to target
moving hotspots, making them less efficient.
The technology has a ways to go before it’s
ready, as the scientists have to find materials
that will last long term, but they’re optimistic
about their progress so far.
After working on this for a few years, the
researchers claim their technique is on par
with the performance of the most common technology
used now: copper heat spreaders, but has the
potential to surpass it.
While new technologies that promise to make
high performance electronics and electric
cars better is exciting, my favorite part
of the story is the researchers who developed
this technology are the same ones who first
observed how cicada wings repelled water.
Back in 2013 they suggested it might be used
as a way to cool devices, and here we are
four years later and they’re doing exactly
what they imagined they would.
Don’t you love the progress of science?
You’re probably watching this video on a
phone or a computer right now, hopefully it’s
cool, but is staring at screens all day really
bad for your eyes?
Check out this episode to find out.
Got a science question you’d like us to
answer?
Let us know down below, be sure to subscribe
and come back here for more Seeker.
Thanks for watching